Salut,
il y a quelque temps,
il y a Franck Ropers qui m'a contacté
pour me proposer qu'on fasse
une vidéo ensemble.
J'ai trouvé ça plutôt cool.
Je connaissais sa chaîne
via Tibo InShape.
DAAMN les gens !
On a décidé de faire  ensemble une vidéo
sur : les réactions face à l'agression.
En clair : comment un corps de lâche,
comme celui-ci, peut-il se défendre ?
Direction le dojo.
[Musique Générique]
Et je suis donc, ayé, enfin, maintenant
avec monsieur Franck !
[Fabien] :Franck Ropers. "Roper" ou "Ropers" ?
[Prononciation ou non du S]
[Franck] : On dit Ropers.
[Le S est prononcé]
[Fab] : Ah ça va alors. Je l'ai bien prononcé.
Depuis le début je dis Ropers.
[Franck] : Tu vas survivre.
[Rires]
[Fab] : Je m'en vais...
Ce mec là il associe la self-défense
mais avec le mental et le physique.
Alors, tu parles que ça m'intéresse !
Quels sont les éléments simples qui peuvent me permettre de me mettre en sécurité
euh... sur un vrai contact physique ?
[Frk] : A un moment donné,
il y a ce qu'on appelle la rupture.
[Fab] : Ouais.
[Frk] : Tu vas forcément basculer en mode physique,
en mode agression.
Alors après , euh...
il faut dire les choses :
il y a 4 profils d'agresseurs.
Tu vas devoir, en fait, agir
en fonction des profils d'agresseurs.
Toi c'est pas un problème,
parce que tu vas vite détecter un peu
comment ils fonctionnent.
[Fab] : Ouais.
[Frk] : Alors, on va les faire
très rapidement :
Tu en as quatre.
Tu as l'agresseur isolé.
Isolé, mais programmé.
En fait, il a décidé et
il a décelé en toi une victime.
[Fab] : Ok.
[Frk] : Bon, comme tu dis,
tu as un corps de lâche...
Moi ça me fait rire parce que...
[Rires de Fabien]
[Frk] : Lâche c'est là !
Lâche, ce n'est pas dans le physique.
Il y a des petits bonhommes
fous furieux
et des costauds qui ne valent rien
dans une situation réelle
parce que :
ici c'est faible.
[Fab - Ironique] ben, je ne vois pas
de quoi vous parlez.
[Frk] C'est agresseur programmé
a programmé son attaque
soit pour te voler,
soit en terme d'agression sexuelle...
Donc c'est quelqu'un,
si tu lui opposes la force,
la détermination,
il peut lâcher facilement
parce que, ce qu'il veut, c'est la facilité.
Lui c'est le professionnel de
l'agression.
"J'ai décidé que celui-là
est une victime..."
S'il voit une difficulté,
il va lâcher l'affaire.
Parce qu'il est lucide.
Il a programmé.
Deuxième catégorie,
c'est l'agresseur non programmé.
Alors là, c'est souvent le gars
qui est sous stupéfiants, sous alcool,
et qui lui, par contre, n'est pas
quelqu'un qui va lâcher facilement
parce qu'il n'a pas la capacité
à te comprendre,
à t'écouter,
donc celui là, malheureusement,
je vais être dur avec toi :
il va falloir lui faire du mal.
[Fab] Ouais...
[Frk] : Pour cesser.
[Frk] Alors, encore une fois,
je t'apprendrai, il y a des techniques de base,
déjà qu'il faut faire, face à
ce genre d'individu.
Donc ça c'est le deuxième.
Le troisième, très compliqué :
c'est ce qu'on appelle
la bande organisée.
Cinq, six garçons, qui ont
décidé de te faire la peau.
[Frk] : de te faire du mal.
[Fab] Et bien j'ai eu ça le 6 janvier 2006,
et j'ai fini aux urgences.
[Frk] Voilà... Alors là, c'est compliqué
parce qu'il y a la suppériorité numérique ;
[Fab] ouais.
[Frk] : Il y a le fait qu'ils sont bien décidés
et qu'ils vont s'organiser avec une stratégie
pour t'entourer et te défoncer.
Ça va être compliqué.
Ça ne veut pas dire
que tu ne peux pas t'en sortir.
Très compliqué.
Et enfin, la quatrième catégorie :
ce sont les agresseurs en groupe non organisés.
Donc là, c'est le petit malin
qui va chauffer les autres.
Alors ça peut être sous alcool...
là tu peux t'en sortir parce qu'il
n'y a pas de structure.
[Fab] : Ouais.
[Frk] : Donc là, il suffit que tu réagisses vite,
et que tu frappes très fort,
et tout...
Donc voilà. Là, on a vu qu'il y a des gens qui seront
raisonnés et des gens non raisonnables.
Première chose à faire quand
tu as une agression,
une fois que tu as vu
à qui tu as affaire,
c'est de mettre tes mains devant.
Le fait de mettre les mains devant,
ça fait un barrage psychologique.
"Je ne veux pas d'histoires ! "
Il ne faut pas se mettre en garde !
Surtout pas, hein ?
[Fab] Oui. Ce n'est pas agressif.
[Frk] Surtout pas.
[Fab] Et, en même temps, ça fait une barrière.
[Frk] Alors, tu peux faire ça...
[Frk] la paix universelle, comme on dit...
[Fab] Ouais.
[Frk] Ça peut être la discussion...
Mais là, mine de rien,
tu es en capacité,
[Frk] avec ces antennes,
[Fab] ouais, ouais.
[Frk] : J'appelle ça des antennes,
de bloquer éventuellement une frappe.
[Fab] Oui, et puis c'est très gênant,
visuellement, pour moi qui...
[Frk] Tu as tout compris.
Donc il y a l'aspect physique.
C'est l'aspect "Bouclier", "Barrage".
Avec des "antennes", pour pouvoir
réagir au cas où.
Au-delà d'un certain seuil,
rythme cardiaque 150 pulsations environ,
tu passes en reptilien.
Donc les blocages qu'on apprend
en salle ne fonctionneront pas.
C'est ceux qui sont reptiliens.
Par contre, le fait d'avoir les mains
va permettre de bloquer, à la source, la frappe.
Et, hyper important !
Tu le sais. C'est l'aspect spychologique.
Le barrage.
Ça gêne.
[Fab] : Ouais.
[Frk] : "Moi je ne veux pas d'histoires, monsieur"
"Je suis un papa".
C'est ce que je dis souvent,
ça fait rire tout le monde,
"non, non"
Et ça gêne.
Et même si la frappe arrive,
tu vas la prendre en fin de course.
Après, la deuxième chose à faire,
à un moment donné,
si tu sens que ça bascule,
c'est de réagir tout de suite
en frappant.
Par contre, il faut faire
des frappes simples.
D'accord ?
Et des frappes qui sont
proches du reptilien,
à savoir : où on met en fonction
des mouvements moteurs grossiers.
Ça veut dire : des choses qui ne vont
pas te demander trop de réflexion.
[Frk] : Moi je dis : le cerveau...
[Fab] Moi je...
[Fab] je me souviens d'un truc sur
ta chaîne qui partait comme ça, comme ça...
[Frk] Voilà, tout à fait.
[Fab] Je me suis dit : Woua, jamais j'aurais pensé à ça!
[Frk] En fait, si tu veux... euh...
S'il y a un cahier des charges à faire
en terme de self-défense :
c'est le moins de techniques possible.
En fait, ce sont des techniques où
tu vas toucher des points vitaux,
ce n'est pas forcément beau,
mais c'est efficace.
Pourquoi ? Parce que tu ne vas pas avoir
à trop réfléchir,
"oui... il faut que je me positionne comme-ci,
que l'angle de mon doigt...
ma clée je dois la faire..."
Non !
Ce sont des frappes directes.
Chemin le plus court possible.
D'accord ?
Avec des mouvements moteurs grossiers.
[Fab - Approuvant] hmm, hmm.
[Frk] : Des grosses frappes, où le
cerveau reptilien va pouvoir suivre.
[Frk] C'est compliqué de faire un coup de pied retourné
[Fab] C'est sûr, oui...
[Frk] Ça c'est pour les arts martiaux.
Dans la rue ce n'est pas possible
car ce n'est pas au même niveau du cerveau.
[Frk] C'est plus profond, c'est grégaire, c'est le reptilien...
[Fab] C'est pas le même [???]...
[Frk] Voilà ! Donc moi si j'avais à
t'apprendre une technique,
c'est de dire :
1 - T'habituer à une mise en situation de stress.
Te pousser régulièrement.
Pour que tu t'habitues aux insultes,
que tu t'habitues à la pression
psychologique de l'agresseur.
T'habituer !
Que ce ne soit pas l'inconnu.
Donc ton cerveau va mémoriser.
Première chose.
[Fab] C'est hyper-intéressant.
La répétition pour une imprégnation,
vraiment,
de ne pas avoir à conscientiser
ce que tu vas faire après.
[Frk] Voilà. Donc le premier truc
c'est d'éviter l'inconnu.
Donc, je vais te pousser plusieurs fois,
je vais t'insulter une trentaine de fois,
tu vas voir : ton cerveau va s'habituer
aux insultes.
Deuxièmement : mettre ses mains.
[Frk] C'est super important.
[Fab] Je suis un papa rangé...
[Frk] Si tu es là...
[Réagissant à la réplique de Fab] Voilààà...
tu ne pourras pas bloquer.
Troisième chose : apprendre des techniques
passe-partout très simples.
Que tu peux faire en 5 minutes.
Une fois que tu connais
le type d'agresseur,
une fois que tu t'habitues à
une situation stressante,
aussi bien physiquement
que mentalement,
tu mes les mains devant
et après... on t'a appris les techniques.
Alors, la problématique chez toi,
comme tu es quelqu'un de bien éduqué,
c'est, justement : switcher.
[Fab] Ouais...
[Frk] Quand il le faudra.
[Fab] Ouais, c'est çà !
[Fab] C'est de déterminer vraiment
le moment, euh...
[Frk] Alors, en fait, c'est un choix qui est
purement personnel,
alors, ça se travaille
- là, on ne peut pas le travailler -
ça se travaille avec des mises en situation.
[Fab] Ok.
[Frk]En fait, je vais t'apprendre à gérer
jusqu'au seuil de stress.
Et à un moment donné,
tu vas le sentir :
tu ne pourras plus gérer
physiquement et mentalement.
Alors, physiquement, c'est souvent
lié à ton cardio-vasculaire.
[Fab] Ouais.
[Frk] Comme tu n'es pas un "physique" de base,
tu vas sentir que tu vas commencer
à suffoquer, tu vas paniquer.
Là je vais te dire : "Il faut que tu y ailles !"
[Fab] Ouais.
[Frk] Parce que si tu attends, tu vas te soumettre.
Et lui va se renforcer parce qu'il
va sentir la domination.
Par contre, psychologiquement :
on ne sait pas.
Toi seul le sait.
Il y a des gens, qui ne sont pas habitués,
qui ont un seuil très important
avant d'arriver à la bascule.
[Fab] Ouais.
[Frk] Tu te rappelles, la bascule,
c'est le moment où
ça va être en panique.
Et la problématique c'est que
la self-défense, comme ton métier,
ça se travaille en amont.
[Frk] Ce n'est pas le jour J qu'il faut
te poser des questions.
[Fab] Ouais, c'est ça !
[Frk] Et, par exemple, c'est ridicule
de dire à quelqu'un,
de ton poids, de ton gabarit,
d'aller chercher le combat
mais loyal,
face à quelqu'un qui est entraîné.
Donc tu vas être obligé d'utiliser
la ruse.
[Fab] Ouais...
[Frk] La stratégie mentale pour l'affaiblir.
Et pouvoir, soit te sauver...
C'est le meilleur des cas, hein ?
Juridiquement, financièrement,
et sur le plan physique...
Mais faut dire les choses, hein ?
Mais si tu sais que tu ne peux pas faire
autrement, tu te dis : "là il faut que j'y aille."
Parce que si je dure, ça ne va pas
être bon pour moi.
Parce qu'il y a la supériorité
physique.
C'est ta détermination et ta capacité à
connaître ce qu'on appelle le profil de l'agression.
Les gens pensent que :
"Oh là, là. Ça ne va pas bien se passer,
mes jambes... je tremble.
Je sens la blancheur du visage..."
Mais non !
C'est l'adrénaline. C'est excellent !
C'est pour mieux te sauver,
c'est pour mieux combattre,
moins sentir les coups.
Si tu te fais couper
comme le sang est parti des périphéries
ça te sauve la vie ;
Les jambes qui tremblent, c'est normal,
c'est l'énergie qui vient pour courir...
Et en fait, une fois que tu sais que
c'est pour te rendre service,
et non pas te mettre en difficulté,
mais exploite !
C'est ton arme !
Ce qui fait que tu as des gens
de petit gabarit
qui, lors d'une agression,
pètent un câble
et démontent un costaud.
[Fab] Ouais, c'est hyper-intéressant.
[Fab] Merci beaucoup Franck.
[Frk] Mais de rien.
[Fab] Merci à toi.
Je, euh.... Ce n'est pas exactement
ce que j'avais prévu,
je pensais qu'on allait faire
des démos, mais en fait on va garder ça...
[Frk] Ah, mais je peux te taper
si tu veux...
[Rires]
[Frk] S'il n'y a que ça...
[Fab] Écoutez, je ne veux pas de frake monsieur.
[Fab] Je ne veux pas de problèmes.
[Frk] Voilà, tu as retenu la première technique.
[Fab] Ben j'apprends vite...
[Rires]
[Frk] Tu vois, je vais ça avec ma main...
[Frk] et je frappe de l'autre côté.
[Fab] Ouais, c'est ça...
[Frk] Ben, c'est un peu ton métier...
[Fab] C'était génial !
Je vous conseille vraiment,
sincèrement, de découvrir
la chaîne de Franck.
Parce que, pour tout ce
que tu dis là,
quand je regarde les vidéos de Franck
ça me rappelle ce qui peut se passer,
que ça existe,
et comme ça existe,
ça veut dire que je peux m'y préparer
et ce n'est pas grave.
Et avec un truc très rassurant
qu'il y a dans les vidéos de Franck,
qui est :
la meilleure solution c'est la fuite.
Donc, si tu analyses tout,
si tu es capable d'avoir une conscience
à 360, etc...
ça va t'aider.
Et là, je vous en dis trop !
La suite ça se passe sur la chaîne
de Franck Ropers !
Merci beaucoup Franck.
[Fab] Merci à toi.
[Frk] Merci à toi.
Me voilà de retour au bureau.
Je pense qu'on fera une suite à cette vidéo
avec Franck, sur la chaîne,
d'ici peut-être six mois... ou en fin d'année.
Pour aller dans les techniques,
physiquement parlant.
Vraiment.
Sur le tapis.
J'ai rencontré vraiment
quelqu'un de génial.
Je veux le remercier encore une fois.
Très agréable et extrêmement
intéressant dans son domaine.
Comme d'habitude,
vous pouvez liker cette vidéo
et vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous très bientôt,
sûrement samedi matin.
Ciao !
[Musique Générique de fin]